old men with treasure chests creepy real
estate agents who are also very handsome
and the best movie directed by Michael
Scott since threat level midnight
dangerous lies is another Netflix
original in the same vein as 2019 secret
obsession not quite movie of the week
not quite full-blown feature quality you
may have seen the directors previous
work such as it's Christmas Carol
witness to murder and who can forget
Apple mortgage cake now you might be
asking yourself think story why are you
covering this movie well quite frankly
with no work I'm about to go all Jack
Torrance over my wife and the sad thing
is I don't even have a wife so you're
gonna suffer through this like I did
dangerous lies tells the story of Katie
Franklin a personal caregiver who
inherits the estate of an old man she's
known for for months unfortunately for
her Katie must deal with a prodding
detective nefarious lawyer nagging
employer ex-con and even her own husband
to get to the bottom of a murder that's
riddled in mystery it takes about 24
minutes for the story to get going when
Katie finds her patient Leonard has died
so she brings in her husband to check
out the body not sure if that's protocol
and he finds a key conveniently under
the dead man's hand a key that leads to
a treasure chest to a mystery newspaper
clipping about a car accident and a dead
woman presumably Leonard's wife but
don't worry none of this matters to the
story and it's never brought up again
now I don't know if the production
designers were just having a laugh but
if you read the article to the right
here it's all about Al Capone being
mayor of Chicago and celebrating
Oktoberfest in the 1960s hey he was
never mayor of Chicago and B he died in
1947 hidden in a secret compartment
within the chest Adam and Katie find
close to $100,000 in cash something they
decide to keep secret but that really
doesn't matter since 10 minutes later
they end up owning the house meet Julia
Byron Kim a lawyer who says she
represents Leonard and informs Katie
that since Leonard had no family he
decided to leave everything to her the
only thing stopping Katie from enjoying
this windfall is detective chess ler who
seems to think something is suspicious
about
an old man leaving his entire fortune to
someone he's only known for four months
now was simple toxicology report would
have shown that Leonard had an overdose
but for some reason the film doesn't
explain this
I can't even prove that he didn't die a
natural death why why wasn't there a
report done we later find out this
creepy real-estate agent Mickey Hayden
was the real culprit behind overdosing
Leonard he's not a real estate agent at
all but a former jewel thief looking for
his ex-partner stash of diamonds a stash
of diamonds worth three million dollars
that Adam finds hidden in the shed out
back where Leonard's former gardener
Ethan live Ethan and Hayden worked
together in stealing the diamonds but
Ethan was double-crossed and shot but
it's never explained how he evaded both
Hayden and the police with such a
grievous injury you'd think if you're on
the verge of death you'd go to a
hospital maybe stash the diamonds
somewhere else or just turn yourself in
but Ethan went back to the shed where he
died and no one seemed to notice for
over two years and the twists keep on
coming when it's revealed that Julia was
in cahoots with Hayden did I just say
Koontz
goddamn right in exchange for getting
his sentence down to two years Julia
would get a cut of the three million
dollars worth of diamonds hold on I just
want to play this clip for a second a
plea bargain is charges down to two
years I traced Doyle back to when he
worked for Leonard
wait why did she even need Hayden she
was the one who tracked Ethan down she
knew about the diamonds why hook up with
a crazed ex felon when you could have
used this info yourself and avoided
things getting messy but everything is
saved when detective Chesser arrives on
the scene and makes quick work of the
crazy lawyer the only question that
remains where are the diamonds with the
diamond
well we do learn Adams final words are
in the garden yet Katie four months
later hasn't bothered to follow up on
the friggin last words of her husband
maybe this is also the first time in
four months she's turned on her
sprinkler but it reveals that the
Diamonds were buried about less than an
inch in the garden because if you're
gonna bury three million worth of
diamonds you just put him right on top
where an easy downpour of rain could
wash him away also she's pregnant
because why not to be honest it's a
pretty sad ending this kid's gonna grow
up without a father Adam the guy who was
going to school so he could get a better
job and support his family dies and our
main character doesn't really change
throughout the film the Katie we see at
the beginning is the same Katie we see
at the end but she's pregnant and I
guess even though we found out the will
was forged she gets to keep it which is
kind of cool that's it for dangerous
lies just thought I'd throw a quick
video out today but I want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below make sure
to LIKE and subscribe and if you haven't
seen it check out my video on secret
obsession for more bad takes you can
also follow me on twitter at things
story whitey until next time remember
daddy loves you very much